So let's not add some functionality to our
JavaScript to actually show these Health
pools
Be what they're supposed to be so my hero
Health should be 100 in my Dillon Health
should be 150
So we'll see how to kind of get those drawn
onto the page and that's awesome make it so
every time I click this attack button
It is reactive and responsive to our attack
So from here the first step I want to take
is I'm going to go ahead and not make this
100 we'll put a span here
When I actually put 100 back inAnd let's add
an ID.
And this ID is going to be what we're going
to Target in our JavaScript so I need to
make sure I have something in here
To be a placeholder when the page loadsBut I
also need this ID. To be able to.
Access it later in JavaScript so I might
just repeat myself there
So first things first we got that Span in
there with that hero health
and that span gives us the ability to wrap
that number within a
Element selector an element so we can put
that ID on there
So let's head over to our main.js
And let's go ahead and add a line hereSo
we'll say const hero Elam here.
Equals document so we're going to Target our
DomGet element by ID.
And we're going to choose that ID we had
earlier so is hero health
So what's your name I'm going to rename this
hero health elim
Cuz this is going to be the entire element
so let's go ahead and console logHero
healthy I'm here.
So let's save thisLet's go ahead and label
this really quick.
Save this go to our Dom
From here when I click attack we can see
that I'm actually targeting that specific
span
Whenever I'm creating that Dom from whenever
we're creating that variable from that get
element by ID
So that's perfect that's exactly what I want
to select because I want to be able to
change this number in here from 100 to
whatever the new number is when they get
attacked
So now I'm going to do that is I'm actually
going to say hero Health dot ElmThat enter
text.
And we just want this to equalThe new hero
health.
So let's save thatLet's refresh.
So before I hit this attack buttonWhen I hit
it we should see this hero Health go down by
5:00 every time I click.
Due to that selector so let's click
itAwesome.
And we can see over here every time I'm
clicking it we get a new span with that
additional 85
And that's only happening because of we're
inserting this 85 right here into that span
So perfect now let's do the same thing for
our villain's health
So let's go ahead and concept out as well
we'll say Conn's villain Health Elam
Equals document get element by IDAnd we're
going to Target that villain Health as well.
And this is going to give us accessWho's
going to give us access to that span.
We're going to do the exact same thing as
well so we'll see villain healthIntertext.
Equals our new villain health because at
this point we subtracted it by 10
So if we come back here we should see every
time we click thisWe're actually making
those changes on the screen.
The right now every time we click
It goes well actually we won't talk about
that yet we'll add that later
Before we continue to our next portion of
ourActually no.
I'll probably just create everything
outYeah.
I mean there's not a whole lot to be honest
I mean Vocal Point cue that I am continuing
ZachAnd three.
TwoWhat.
There's one thing I want to point out though
when we continue to attack
We can actually go hit zero and go negative
Let's make sure we add some functionality
and make it so we if you hit zero we can't
go below zero and will you actually just win
So for thatWe can do it first with our
villains Health here.
We can say we want to make this conditional
So we want to make essentially we want to
return so stop this entire everything after
this line
If the villain's health is less than or
equal to zero
Also want to make sure if my health is less
than or equal to 0
I am a defeated as well so I don't want to
be able to continue
I don't want to be able to continue the game
on even if I don't have it so it's actually
get rid of this
I'm actually going to do thatI'll add that
in later. So villain health is.
Great or less than or equal to zeroLet's go
ahead and just return straight out of this
function.
Cuz our return is just going to be a hard
stop
And I'll show you what I mean
So every time ISo every time I hit attack.
We get all the console log so let me clear
it
So I hit attack now you will see his health
is at zero and we get our about to attack
villain and all that but because we put that
conditional statement there we should only
get the hero Health now
Because after that line so it's going to do
all the hero stuff but it's going to hit
that conditional
And it's actually going to be zero at that
point
So I can show that off as well using a
debugger really quick
This is a great tool to use as well I'm a
huge debugger fan I use the all the time
whenever you're trying to figure out
something's wrong with your code and all
this is this is the line I want it to start
debugging on once I have my console open
So if I have it open right away as soon as I
hit this function
Didn't workI didn't save.
So as soon as I hit this button it's
actually going to pop this debugger upAnd
it's going to go through all the code but
we'll just.
Go through it for now and let's actually
close our console cuz I don't want to go
through the debugger yet
I want to go through it this moment so right
now we're at 30 health and 10 villain health
so I should go through this
Instance is villain Health less than zero
nope so we can actually use this step over
And it's going to hit this conditional it's
going to step over and it's going to make
those calculations again
But now that it's at zero health
It's going to hit this debugger it when it
took the five Health from our hero it's
going to say zero less than or equal to zero
oh it is
So step into that it's actually going to hit
this returnAnd then it's just going to exit
out of it.
So I'm still able to hit it but all the code
after this returnIt just skips because that
conditional is true.
So we will want to do the same thing with
Our Hero's Health as well
Cuz we won't want to allow him to continue
attacking eitherSo let's put the same thing
we'll say if.
Our hero health is less than or equal to
zero
We want to returnBut this time I'm going to
do something a little differently actually
going to return an alert.
This is going to be a cool window alert and
we're just going to say theCode Works
crusader.
IsDead.
And let's show you how that will work as
well so I'll actually make my house zero or
go down quicker so I can go to zero first
Let's refresh thisAnd when I hit attack
here.
You can see the code Works Crusader is dead
So I can no longer attack this is a not
allowing me to attack any longer
But let's make sure everything is working
properly so if I doIf I do expect a five
save this.
Go back to our application and let's just
check to make sure everything's working the
way we want so villain's health is at zero
But we notice when we keep attacking Our
Heroes Health continues to go down even
though
The villain is technically defeated so he
shouldn't be able to continue attacking us
even when we are attacking
So somewhere in our functionality we need to
add a or statement
To make it so we stop attacking each other
all together
So we'll add a couple things here we'll
actually add an order here
And we'll say if the hero health is less
than or equal to zero as well
The main thing is we want to return
something hereSo we want to say if the boss
is health.
WowExcuse me the villain's health.
So we want to return something if the
villains
health is 0 or below so we'll say
ifVillain's health.
Is less than or equal to 0 let's do
something similar like that alert that we
had above
I want to returnAlert. And we'll say the
code works.
Crusader Vanquish the coding virus that's
going to be the name of our villain here
No reason to there's no reason to beat a
dead horse you know
He's already dead we don't want to keep
attacking them that's kind of rude and mean
you kind of prove a point
So let's say this and head back to our
applicationAnd let's just test this to make
sure it works the way we want.
So we are going to beat them so it's
attackAnd we get that pop alert to not allow
us to continue tacking.
And neither one of our health continue to go
down